pas un mot pas un bruit
la concentration est à son maximum le
travail à la plume et à l'encré de chine
demande une précision à toute épreuve et
une imagination débordante
comme quand on a l'habitude de regarder
les nuages et qu'on imagine des formes
qu'on voit à l'intérieur
le but c'est que les enfants dans les
fonds et les formes d'encre qu'ils ont
fait un nom en arrière qui puisse
imaginer bas un univers un paysage des
personnages et utilisez la couleur pour
réhausser ses formes là et donner vie en
fait alors à leur dessein insectes ou
paysage des univers délicat et poétique
une véritable découverte pour les plus
jeunes hafsa ibrahim utilisent cet outil
pour la première fois j'ai mis des
décors et des quelques là j'ai fait un
ours avec des couleurs massé joule
et là j'ai fait des points el guerrouj
des couleurs les belles couleurs elle
était belle et des et j'aime bien les
stylos a pu après une escale en asie
proposé par la ville de plaisir pendant
les vacances
les prochains ateliers vous emmèneront
au japon pour réaliser des maquis aux
fruits ou apprendre à concevoir une
petite table en bois